vous vous m'entendez
de Madame Oriane Sybille le conseiller
environnement et de Madame Montaine
blonzard responsable des relations avec
le Parlement
et enfin pour France urbaine monsieur
Étienne Chauffour en charge des
mobilités de l'éducation Petite Enfance
Jeunesse des solidarités et de
l'outre-mer et de Monsieur Pierre Marie
ganousi adjoomer de Marseille en charge
du plan école du bâti de la construction
de la rénovation et du patrimoine
scolaire accompagné de Madame Sarah Bou
Sader responsable des relations avec le
Parlement je précise à l'attention de
Monsieur ganozzi que la mission
d'information pourrait
pour aimer c'est souhaiter se déplacer à
Marseille au mois de mai
ce poids est encore à confirmer ce qui
pourrait permettre de compléter son
propos de ce matin par des visites de
terrain on voit toujours mieux quand on
avec les pieds voilà
l'association des petites villes de
France n'a pas été en mesure de
participer à ces tables rondes et on
verra par la suite des réponses
écrites au questionnaire
je rappelle également que cette audition
donnera lieu à un contrôle du écrit qui
sera annexé à notre rapport et que son
enregistrement vidéo sera accessible sur
le site du Sénat un questionnaire vous a
été adressé en amont de cette réunion
nous n'aurons peut-être pas et c'est
vraisemblable le temps d'épuiser ce
matin tous les sujets qu'il comporte
mais vous pourrez nous adresser par la
suite des éléments écrits qui
enrichiront notre réflexion je vous
saurais reconnaissant de lors de vos
exposer de vous limiter
un temps de parole de 10 minutes environ
afin de permettre un temps d'échange
après vos interventions avant de vous
donner la parole notre rapport est
rapporteur Nadège avait va vous poser
une première série de questions
madame la rapporteur vous avez la parole
c'est bon ça marche
[Musique]
en totale soit sur la construction et la
rénovation
qui est-ce qui démarre
monsieur le Président Madame la
rapporteur merci pour pour ces questions
alors pour ce qui concerne les
statistiques intercommunalité de France
ne recense pas
de statistiques les seules statistiques
dont nous disposons sont celles qui ont
été mises en évidence dans le de leur
apport de l'ingénieur de Marc sur le
nombre d'écoles et le nombre de mètres
carrés donc à notre connaissance il y a
aujourd'hui 52 455 établissements en
France et donc 44902 écoles
et 62% de ces écoles sont dans des
communes de moins de 10000 habitants ces
écoles
représentent environ 30% des dépenses
énergétiques de nos intercommunalités
les modes de chauffage sont extrêmement
variés donc il est difficile de et nous
ne disposons pas de statistiques les
besoins de réhabilitation sont très
importants sur le coût au mètre carré il
a explosé en termes de rénovation depuis
deux ans compte tenu de la situation que
nous connaissons avec l'augmentation
très importante du coup des matériaux on
était environ à 300 euros du mètre carré
il y a trois ans pour une rénovation
énergétique je pense que on est
aujourd'hui au delà de ce cours au mètre
carré voilà mais il y a ce que vous avez
mis en évidence à travers votre question
c'est la nécessité de recenser pour
avoir une idée plus précise et surtout
c'est ce que nous avons nous commencé à
faire interco par interco de prioriser
puisque aujourd'hui la difficulté et la
priorisation en effet nous avons le
décrétaire de la loi Elan respecté
beaucoup d'écoles dans des petites
communes sont en dessous de ce seuil de
la loi Elan et par conséquent quand on
priorise et bien on priorise avec les
établissements les équipements notamment
les équipements ludiques les États les
équipements liés par exemple
enfin les patinoires les piscines ou
également les équipements chargés de en
charge de l'assainissement et de la
qui sont très consommateurs d'énergie et
donc quand nous voulons prioriser on se
rend compte que les le bâtis scolaire
n'est pas forcément on va dire le plus
urgent c'est une vraie course de fond
il est possible d'enchaîner à deux voies
pour ce qui concerne France urbaine un
petit peu comme intercommunalité de
France on n'a pas ses données
statistiques en revanche vous avez fait
référence dans l'introduction de
l'inquiétude du milieu rural c'est
également une inquiétude dans le milieu
urbain évidemment le volume d'école dans
les grandes villes est beaucoup plus
importante pour autant les enjeux sont
double à la fois parce que nous avons
des enjeux de rénovation énergétique etc
et par ailleurs parce que nous sommes
confrontés à des enjeux démographiques
qui peuvent soit amener à reconstruire à
grandir etc soit au contraire à
réaménager l'exemple de Paris est un
exemple probant donner une seconde vie à
des bâtiments qui ont été des bâtiments
scolaires
par ailleurs sur le plan financier c'est
un petit peu notre inquiétude c'est que
nous avons été associés
à des investissements lourds pour
l'amélioration de la éducative donc le
dédoublement des classes et quelque
chose que nous avons fortement financé
nous sommes sollicités en ce moment par
le ministre de l'éducation sur l'égalité
sociale qui demandera des efforts je
pense que les départements et les
régions ont dû l'évoquer et nous sommes
par ailleurs volontariste sur
globalement les efforts climatiques mais
tout ça je dirais si on les empile va
avoir pour conséquence que à un moment
les collectivités tout tomber les
collectivités locales ce qui n'est pas
le cas des départements des régions qui
n'ont pas été confrontés au dédoublement
de classe mais pour nous c'est
extrêmement difficile peut-être
Pierre-Marie je pense que c'est un
éclairage plus précis
merci Étienne je peux prendre 10 minutes
où je réponds essentiellement à vos
questions
le temps que je veux faut pas me lancer
là dessus parce que là
très bien merci merci beaucoup donc pour
tout le monde sait que l'état des écoles
à Marseille et déplorable ça a même fait
la une d'un célèbre journal il y a il y
a quelques années et pour nous donc
nouvelle municipalité à Marseille nous
en avons fait notre priorité priorité au
cours de la campagne priorité dans notre
action au quotidien et ce qui a été très
médiatisé c'est le plan école qui a été
signé même dans la main avec l'État et
la ville de Marseille avec le président
de la République et le maire Benoît
Paillon qui tous les deux se sont rendus
compte que l'état des écoles était
catastrophique que pour une simple
communauté commune communauté ça serait
compliqué de parvenir à remettre à fond
à la totalité des écoles donc c'est la
raison pour laquelle il y a eu cette ce
plan école de à plus d'un milliard
d'euros qui a été qui a été signé il y a
une société spécifique qui a été créée à
l'attention à l'intention de ces de d'à
peu près les deux le tiers de des écoles
de Marseille et le corollaire de ça
c'était l'idée j'en avais déjà parlé au
cours de réunions avec France urbaine
c'est que ce que à Lyon obtenir comme
expertise dans le cadre de notre travail
sur le plan école nous allions pouvoir
le mutualiser avec d'autres communes qui
le souhaiteraient c'est d'ailleurs la
raison pour laquelle nos équipes à
Marseille on travaillait même dans la
main avec la cellule du batiscolaire qui
a rédigé les différentes fiches sur le
bâtis scolaire qui ont été publiées à
quelques il y a quelques mois et en fait
ça ce travail a été fait vraiment en
corrélation avec des équipes de
Marseille qui sont à pied d'oeuvre
depuis depuis plus de deux ans
pour répondre aux questions que vous
avez posées sur les les statistiques en
termes de salle de classe on est à peu
près en moyenne à 60 mètres carrés par
classe ce qui fait par élève à 3 mètres
carrés par élève il y a 77000 élèves et
à 3500 salles de classe à Marseille
si on rajoute la totalité du bâti
c'est-à-dire si vous rajoutez donc les
salles de classe comme je viens de le
dire plus les dortoirs les les salles
des maîtres les les espaces communs etc
on se retrouve avec une statistique à
environ 5,2 m2 de par élève et si on
rajoute les cours d'école et si on ne
parle que des cours d'école on est à 8
mètres carrés par élève pour les cours
d'école sachant que à Marseille on a la
particularité d'avoir des écoles de
toute taille il peut y avoir des groupes
scolaires à plus de 600 élèves ce qui
est quasiment fait ce qui est au collège
en réalité et il y en a même qui sont
toutes petites on a par exemple alors il
n'a qu'une seule mais il y a une école
avec une classe voilà et parfois on a
des donc je vous disais la moyenne elle
est de 8 mètres carrés par élève mais ça
veut pas dire qu'on est de manière
uniforme à ces 8 mètres carrés on a des
notamment dans les zones un peu
périphériques de Marseille dans des dans
des cours de cours d'école très
généreuses très vastes en l'inverse dans
l'hypercentre on est beaucoup plus à
l'étroit avec un nombre d'élèves qui ne
se qui ne se Démont pas d'ailleurs c'est
une particularité de Marseille par
rapport à Paris par exemple où on a une
pression démographique qui reste
importante alors qu'à Paris il y a une
baisse de la démographie à Marseille on
est à 77000 chiffres qui qui ne
diminuent pas depuis plusieurs années et
dans les prévisions que nous avons avec
les agences d'urbanisme chiffre qui ne
diminuera pas non plus dans les cinq ou
dix prochaines années donc c'est
statistiques là que je vous ai donné
sont des statistiques à l'instant T en
termes de production d'énergie qu'est-ce
qui chauffe les petites marseillaises et
les petits marseillais il y a une école
sur 470 qui est encore au fioul elle a
connu Gaston Defferre elle devrait
disparaître très rapidement
sinon l'essentiel de ces de ces écoles
sont au gaz
pour les pour les trois quarts d'entre
elles et un quart à l'électricité sur
les chauffages au gaz nous sommes en
train de nous avons voté il y a déjà un
an et demi un grand plan de remplacement
des chaudières donc les plus anciennes
vont être remplacés par des chaudières
mais pour l'instant ce que nous avons
trouvé c'est des chaudières à gaz à
condensation alors c'est toujours du gaz
mais on consomme trois fois moins donc
on reste sur 10 euros carbure mais on a
une production qui est beaucoup plus
efficiente que ce qui peut y avoir par
le passé là nous sommes en train de
réfléchir à quel type de nouvelle
production de chauffage on pourrait
avoir il y a beaucoup d'idées qui
naissent on a des startups qui proposent
des choses notamment il y a il y avait
une entreprise qui proposait le
recyclage de de palettes de supermarché
vous savez le problème c'est que alors
sur le papier ça me semblait extrêmement
intéressant en réalité c'est qu'on s'est
rendu compte que brûler ses palettes
dégager des des particules et c'est
particules on avait un problème pour les
pour les recycler donc
on a annulé ça ceci étant nous sommes en
train de chercher et nous favorisons
autant que faire ce peu les nouvelles
productions d'énergie par exemple en
source de chaleur il y a la
thalassothermie qui est développée à
Marseille bon il y a la mer c'est pas un
scoop et donc il y a deux grosses
entreprises françaises qui développent
la thalassothermie donc il s'agit en
fait d'un de d'utiliser la l'énergie de
l'eau de mer pour alors soit chauffer en
hiver soit rafraîchir en été il s'agit
pas de climatisation il s'agit d'un
fresh cooling pour reprendre un terme
adéquate mais bon voilà il faut faire en
gros c'est du rafraîchissement
l'avantage c'est que c'est c'est une
énergie j'ai envie de dire presque
éternelle l'inconvénient il est double
c'est que un ça coûte très cher et puis
deux c'est que il faut être à proximité
de la mer parce que pour l'instant ce
réseau de chaleur n'est disponible que à
proximité de la mer alors peut-être que
dans 10-15 ans on pourra aller plus loin
sur la ville mais à l'instant T c'est là
où nous en sommes en termes de besoins
les besoins sont considérables sur
toutes les écoles il y a une nécessité
pour Marseille mais comme pour toutes
les communes de respecter le décrétaire
or pour respecter ce décrétaire science
absolument gigantesque les
investissements qu'il faut faire nous ce
que nous avons fléchés sur les donc je
parle que des écoles je parle pas des
collèges je parle pas des lycées ce que
nous avons fléchés sur les écoles de
Marseille donc quand même 470 donc ça
c'est quand même beaucoup si on fait sur
mon part par rapport aux autres c'est
quasiment l'équivalent de de la totalité
du Marseille c'est plus de la moitié du
département des Bouches-du-Rhône pour le
pour les pour la scolarisation des des
du à l'école à l'école primaire si on
parle des besoins on est à 1,2 milliards
d'investissements à l'instant T donc
budget 2021 donc si vous rajoutez les
coups de crédit etc vous montez
quasiment à 2 milliards donc on est à
1,2 milliards nécessaires c'est pas que
pour des économies d'énergie mais ce que
nous avons inclus dans nos cahiers des
charges c'est à minim une économie
d'énergie entre 30 et 40%. donc
évidemment le décret tertiaire plus une
mieux value par rapport à ce décrétaire
donc c'est des sommes oui
et ça va pas du coup jusqu'à la
neutralité carbone en fait
d'accord pour certaines si parce que
maintenant nous avons imposé notre
cahier des charges non seulement une
amélioration thermique par
l'amélioration du de des isolants mais
également nous avons systématisé
maintenant la pose de panneaux solaires
ce qui veut dire qu'en fait le bâtiment
va dépenser à peu près autant d'énergie
que ce qu'il arrive à ancrer donc si on
arrivera à une énergie positive alors le
terme exactement
à une neutralité à une neutralité
carbone si absolu c'est ça l'objectif
pour les pour les prochains marchés que
que nous allons lancer donc les besoins
ils sont considérables avec des
stratégies qui peuvent être polymorphes
il y a notamment dans le questionnaire
alors moi je comme je suis un bon élève
alors c'est des formations
professionnelles parce que je suis aussi
professeur d'histoire-géographie donc
moi j'ai répondu à toutes les questions
peut-être qu'on y reviendra après dans
la table ronde mais
qu'est-ce que quel est notre stratégie
notre stratégie elle à Marseille on a
une particularité qui est une somme que
nous sommes dans un climat méditerranéen
et il y a le défi du changement
climatique qu'il faut que nous qu'il
faut que nous relevions comment le faire
d'abord c'est pas facile si on veut
réellement y parvenir c'est les
investissements qui sont considérables
parce que beaucoup des écoles que nous
avons ont été construits dans les années
60 70
qui répondait à un besoin d'abord
d'urgence de répondre aux
baby boom mais qui a été construit la
va-vite avec les écolesgep les écolesgep
que nous avons un petit peu partout en
France mais qui ont la particularité
d'être des passoires thermiques donc on
chauffe les petits oiseaux l'hiver et
puis l'été dès le mois d'avril il fait
extrêmement chaud donc on a des défis
comme ça mais les écoles légères c'est
la même chose et les écoles encore plus
anciennes ferry et Front populaire on
est malheureusement un peu dans le dans
le dans la même dans les mêmes problèmes
donc comment faire plusieurs solutions
isolation par l'extérieur ça coûte plus
cher mais c'est plus efficace et surtout
on ne perd pas de place à l'intérieur
notamment pour l'hyper centre où on a
des vieilles écoles de type ferries ça
peut ça peut être intéressant ce que
nous sommes en train de tester puisque
nous avons voté il y a il y a six mois
un plan canicule ce que nous sommes en
train de tester c'est à l'intérieur des
salles de classe des systèmes de de
brasseurs d'air alors c'est pas des
ventilateurs c'est le système de
brasseurs d'air qui vont permettre en
fait de de baisser la température c'est
pas de la climatisation parce que ça
notre objectif à Marseille n'est pas de
faire exploser la planète donc on veut
vraiment aller vers des vers des
solutions de rafraîchissement d'air sans
pour autant dégager trop d'énergie donc
des brasseurs d'air qui vont permettre
d'améliorer d'améliorer ceci dans les
cours d'école nous allons également
déployer des systèmes de de pré-aux avec
des bâches éventuellement avec des
brumisateurs même si ça peut poser des
petits problèmes en termes de de santé
et d'hygiène parce que parfois il y a
des bon bref il y a des bulles d'air ça
c'est très technique il y a des bulles
d'air qui peuvent rester coincés qui
peuvent éventuellement provoquer plus de
mal que de biens donc on est en train de
déployer ça et nous allons le faire
pendant les vacances de de Pâques
prochaine pour s'adapter à et bien à la
canicule que nous avons connu l'année
dernière dès le début du mois de juin
alors que d'habitude les grosses
chaleurs arrivaient plutôt un mois plus
tard et il y a également quelque chose
sur lequel il me semble très important
c'était écrit derrière dans votre
questionnaire il y a deux choses qui me
semblent important
la première c'est travailler avec les
architectes aujourd'hui il y a trop
d'architectes alors je vais pas me faire
des amis en disant ça mais c'est pas
grave qui se font plaisir en faisant de
magnifiques baies vitrées plein sud nous
avons le cas à Marseille et une école en
plus récente alors c'est pas nous qui
avons validé je dis très tranquillement
mais ça a été fait donc grande baie
vitrée de 6 mètres sur 3 magnifiques
mais dès le mois d'avril il fait 35
degrés dans la salle et ça c'est du vrai
parce que je l'ai moi-même testé donc
voilà il faut expliquer aux architectes
et écrire du coup dans le cahier des
charges parce qu'en réalité la force
publique c'est à elle d'avoir des
exigences fortes là-dessus que les
bâtiments plein sud pourquoi pas mais il
faut que adapter l'architecture
au nouveau climat et donc les grandes
baies vitrées où les grandes verrières
c'est plus possible deuxième chose c'est
et c'est écrit dans votre questionnaire
c'était juste de le dire les usages
c'est quelque chose sur lequel il faut
vraiment travailler par exemple aérer le
soir ou le matin le l'idéal c'est le
soir mais ou le matin très tôt pour
arriver avant qu'il est à voir un
rafraîchissement c'est important et de
la même façon expliquer comment
fonctionne les brassages d'air etc et
petite précision
nous avons fait l'expérience malheureuse
de de construction de l'école récentes
qui sont faites des aquariums donc
certaines écoles ont été construites
comme si c'était des bâtiments de bureau
sauf que dans les écoles on accueille
des enfants on accueille des enseignants
on fait un acte pédagogique faire des
écoles aquarium ce n'est pas
envisageable ce que veulent les
usagers
c'est pouvoir ouvrir les fenêtres c'est
pouvoir entendre les oiseaux c'est
pouvoir éventuellement entendre les
bruits de la cour ou de la rue faire des
aquariums ce n'est pas envisageable et
je vous donne un exemple très simple une
école aquarium plein covid le la VMC est
tombé en panne panique à bord
manifestation de parents d'élèves
qu'est-ce qu'on fait mon Dieu on va tous
mourir donc les écoles aquariumes il
faut éviter autant que faire ce peu
c'est pour ça que nous on insiste
beaucoup sur le mécanique autant que
possible la VMC oui mais pas que et je
m'arrêterai là dessus merci vous pouvez
épouser questionnaire tout de suite donc
vous parliez d'architecte vous savez que
l'expérience m'a appris que le meilleur
des architectes c'est celui avec lequel
on a encore jamais travaillé absolument
c'est la raison on est très déçu madame
on les reçoit la semaine prochaine
une question pour pour Madame Renaud de
Mongon est-ce que vous savez dire quelle
est la part des communes qui ont
délégués ou transférer la compétence
bâtiment scolaire à l'intercommunalité à
leur EPCI
alors pour répondre précisément à cette
question en fait Ardenne Métropole a été
lauréate d'un appel à malfaction
d'intérêt de la snccr qui est le l'appel
à manifestation d'intérêt merisier qui
concerne spécifiquement le bâti scolaire
donc nous avons proposé à l'ensemble des
communes membres 58 communes dans notre
intercommunalité de d'adhérer à ce
programme à ce stade il y en a
7 il y a cette communes en fait qui ont
qui ont adhéré au programme alors ça
consiste en quoi et bien commencer par
mettre en place des audits énergétiques
puis
dans un second temps accompagné les
communes dans les travaux de rénovation
énergétique elles mettent en place la
grosse difficulté que nous avons c'est
que nous avons grâce à ce programme mis
en place des jury de recrutement pour
recruter un économe de flux
nous avons fait deux jurides recrutement
Ardenne métropole nous n'avons toujours
pas d'économes de flux donc nous avons
sous-traité en fait ces audits
énergétiques à
une entreprise à une société pour
pouvoir répondre aux attentes des
communes donc on est au début du
programme on sent qu'il y a une vraie un
vrai besoin chez les communes et notre
notre objectif c'est de faire des
communes modèles et de pouvoir en fait
témoigner de ce qui a été fait et que ça
marche mais il y a un gros travail de
formation pour qu'on arrive à trouver
des énergéticiens et c'est pareil sur
les les conseillers en énergie partagée
qu'on peut avoir dans le département on
ne trouve pas de compétences et pourquoi
parce que
ces jeunes gens ces ingénieurs ces
énergéticiens souvent c'est la loi de
l'offre et de la demande ils vont dans
le privé et on a beaucoup beaucoup de
difficultés à mettre en place ne
serait-ce que cette première étape
d'audit énergétique
merci nous allons à présent à Périgueux
est-ce que vous m'entendez madame le
Maire
oui bonjour monsieur le Président madame
le rapporteur je vais donc intervenir au
nom de l'Association des maires de
France et à vous apporter je l'espère
des réponses courtes et concises aux
questions que vous ne avez posées mais
en préalable je voulais revenir sur un
élément qui me paraît essentiel et
distinguer dans le cadre des typologies
d'écoles trois types d'écoles les écoles
maternelles les écoles élémentaires et
les écoles primaires qui par leur
spécificité induisent des maîtres carrés
différents pour autant pour répondre à
votre question nous avons
je vais donc vous donner le nombre de
mètres carrés en moyenne pour les écoles
primaires sachant qu'une école primaire
c'est une école qui normalement comprend
des maternelles et des éléments terre et
qu'il faut donc pondérer ce chiffre qui
est de 4680 mètres carrés puisque dans
une école maternelle vous avez beaucoup
plus de mètres carrés que dans une école
élémentaire qui sont dédiés à des
fonctions spécifiques comme la salle de
motricité comme les dortoirs et dans la
salle de classe elle-même je tandis que
notre collègue de Marseille indiquait
que la superficie moyenne des classes
était de 60 mètres carrés pour les
élèves pour les écoles de Marseille et
bien c'est ce que nous avons nous aussi
à Périgueux pour les écoles élémentaires
nous avons les superficie supérieures
pour les écoles maternelles qui sur le
plan pédagogique travaillent en atelier
et donc on petite en petit groupe dans
les classes
sur la question
du nombre moyen de mètres carrés par
élève et bien je dirais c'est un peu la
même problématique lorsque vous êtes en
élémentaire vous avez plutôt une
organisation de classe d'élèves au
bureau et donc avec des superficie
moindre qui vont de 1m50 à 2 m² par
élève en revanche dans les maternelles
on est plus autour des 3 mètres carrés
puisque vous êtes vous avez cette
dimension d'ateliers qui nécessite des
espaces dédiés dans la classe le point
lecture le coin le coin jeu le coin un
travail en groupe le coin regroupement
qui demande des mètres carrés
supplémentaires concernant les modes de
chauffage comme nos collègues de les
intercommunalités bien il est difficile
d'avoir
une vision globale pour autant nous
avons des chiffres qui nous sont fournis
donc pour du chauffage au gaz qui est
plutôt utilisé en milieu ben de
d'environ 38% pour l'électricité
alors pardon excusez-moi on a distingué
le chauffage urbain donc pour le
chauffage urbain 10% pour le gaz 38%
pour l'électricité 32% pour le fioul 9%
pour le bois environ 7% et les autres
types d'énergie 4% notamment de type
géothermie ce sont des chiffres qui
préviennent d'une étude qui a été menée
en 2018 par le commissariat général au
développement durable en France
alors comment qualifions nous l'état des
écoles au regard des enjeux de la
transition écologique et bien comme je
disais l'ensemble des des intervenants
précédents c'est très hétérogène et
c'est là où la MF voudrait rappeler la
position que nous portons depuis 2020 il
s'agirait d'avoir des financements de
l'État dédié pour le bâti scolaire alors
dans le cadre des différentes évolutions
notamment de la DETR nous avons vu pour
les territoires les plus fragilisés sur
le plan économique des lignes apparaître
et il nous apparaît qu'aujourd'hui il
une ligne spécifique notamment au titre
du fond vert sur le bâti scolaire pour
toutes les écoles de tous les
territoires qu'on soit en milieu urbain
danse en milieu rural ou en milieu
urbain de type ville moyenne
il faudrait aussi avoir une
clarification des aides et une véritable
visibilité à destination des élus parce
qu'aujourd'hui un éluc lorsqu'il veut
monter ses dossiers de financement pour
financer ces opérations de rénovation du
bâti scolaire et bien il est en
difficulté donc il faudrait qu'on ait un
panel des aides mobilisables avec des
cahiers des charges qui soient précis
des dossiers de subvention qui soient
simplifiées pour que toutes les écoles
puissent y répondre parce que nous
portons que il y a notamment les maires
de France quel que soit le type de
commune sont très très attachés à leur à
leurs écoles c'est d'ailleurs tout
l'enjeu que nous avons dans lequel nous
sommes aujourd'hui sur les moyens
humains qui sont consacrés à l'école
dans le cadre des cartes scolaires donc
tous les mers sont très attachés à
l'école ils investissent beaucoup dans
ces dans ces bâtiments c'est la raison
pour laquelle il nous faut à la fois des
outils clairs pour financer le bâti
scolaire mais aussi une projection au
moins à trois ans autour de charte de
chartillerie l'éducation nationale et
les élus pour avoir une projection sur
les moyens humains parce qu'il faut que
l'on sorte de cette logique ou les élus
investissent dans du bâtiment et voilà
leur place fermée à court ou moyen terme
enfin pour terminer nous voulions
attirer votre attention sur les mètres
carrés qui doivent être mis à
disposition dans les écoles pour les
autres fonctions pour les fonctions de
restauration et pour les fonctions du
périscolaire qui complètent la palette
des mesures éducatives au bénéfice de
tous les enfants et que nous avons
sollicité auprès de la CNAV dans le cas
de la nouvelle coche 2023 2027 des
moyens financiers dédiés au financement
du bâti périscolaire
merci beaucoup et à présent nous allons
dans la Loire
ou madame Isabelle Dugelay maire de la
grêle
doit nous attendre oui bonjour à tous
merci de nous consulter sur ce sujet
très très important comme vient de le
dire ma collègue effectivement tous les
maires sont très très attachés à leur
école et peut-être encore plus les mers
ruraux que les autres puisque ils savent
aussi que la que la vie de leur petite
commune dépend beaucoup de l'activité
autour de l'école donc effectivement la
situation est très très hétérogène aussi
d'une commune à l'autre alors moi je
n'aurais pas de chiffres précis à vous
donner sur les moyennes de classe ou les
ou les le nombre de mètres carrés ou les
types de chauffage qui sont très divers
et variés et je pense que les chiffres
de la MF sont tout à fait
adaptables au monde rural si ce n'est
peut-être le chauffage urbain bien sûr
et le gaz le gaz de ville n'étant pas
déployé partout
mais après voilà moi je voulais surtout
intervenir sur les difficultés que
pouvait avoir les petites communes ne
peut par rapport aux audits énergétiques
et la difficulté pour avoir des gens
qualifiés qui puissent réaliser ses
études les le nombre d'études préalables
qui sont
à mettre en place avant de définir un
projet
c'est cette difficulté de maîtrise
d'œuvres et de financement alors dès le
début d'un projet il faut commencer à
financer ses études ce qui parfois est
difficile pour des communes avec de tout
petits budgets
et globalement après c'est la question
des financements qui qui peut définir ce
qui se réalisera ou pas effectivement je
souhaiterais que le fond vert est des
lignes dédiées pour pour les écoles
globalement que ce soit pas qu'un mirage
parce que on nous a beaucoup vendu ce
fond vert mais effectivement on sait
qu'il le montant limité par département
et c'est les sommes seront très vite
atteintes à mon sens par rapport à tous
les besoins qui émergent et les souhaits
des élus aussi de s'engager dans la
transition écologique
voilà des difficultés particulières
aussi pour le monde rural par rapport au
regroupement pédagogique
ou des villes centre qui accueillent des
élèves de communes voisines qui seuls
doivent supporter des charges très
conséquentes
la visibilité aussi qui a comme le
disait ma collègue par rapport aux
fermetures de classe qui peuvent
intervenir
de façon des fois inattendue et pas
toujours très compréhensible
par les élus sur sur des petites écoles
où on ferme beaucoup plus facilement les
classes que quand les ouvre
donc tout est tout est lié en fait
voilà et puis des inquiétudes de Ben
depuis 2020 la pénurie le coût des
matériaux l'inflation le manque de main
d'oeuvre dans les entreprises tout
toutes ces difficultés comme dans tous
les projets que peuvent avoir les
communes
l'attachement effectivement des des mers
à leur école et l'école reste une des
compétences
les plus importantes que les élus ne
sont pas prêts à transférer aux
communautés de communes voilà ils sont
prêts à travailler ensemble la
mutualiser en tout cas c'est vraiment le
sujet sur lequel
ils veulent le garder la main
voilà je
pense que c'est l'essentiel de ce que je
pouvais vous dire merci beaucoup merci
merci à vous madame la rapporteur alors
une remarque pour monsieur ganosi dans
le cadre de rénovation d'école est-ce
que vous avez un
retour d'expérience des lycées qui sont
faits à l'étranger et notamment via les
Français de l'étranger
on les a rencontrés la semaine dernière
et ils ont cette analyse que vous avez
sur comment ventil mieux la circulation
pour éviter de mettre de la
climatisation et je pense qu'il y a un
retour d'expérience assez intéressant
pour vous à aller chercher ils font ils
font un
lycée qui est aussi ouvert un peu sur la
ville du côté de Séville où il pourrait
y avoir des gens pourraient quasiment se
promener dans certains endroits en fait
dédiés dédiés au lycée il pourrait y
avoir mutualisation
euh d'un d'un certain nombre
d'équipements et notamment sur après
tout ce qui est ils sont souvent dans
des pays où parfois il fait très très
chaud donc ils ont un temps d'avance sur
l'adaptation voilà c'était la petite
remarque on pourra effectivement vous
mettre en relation ils vont être très
content je les mets en relation avec
plein de monde ils vont avoir plein de
demandes
j'avais une autre question où on a
évoqué tout à l'heure les difficultés
que ça pouvait être pour les petites
communes et les plus grandes de s'y
retrouver à la fois en ingénierie en
termes d'aide et autres sur ce type de
bâtiment selon vous est-ce que la
logique d'un guichet unique qui
permettrait en fait de coordonner
l'accompagnement des collectivités
pourrait y répondre ou pas
qu'est-ce qui démarre
oui moi je pense que c'est une que c'est
une bonne idée parce qu'en fait un des
problèmes que nous avons c'est que
aujourd'hui pour les entreprises il a il
y a peu d'entreprises en réalité
compétente pour réaliser des travaux
énergétiques efficients donc la première
des choses ce serait que la force
publique puisse mettre de l'ordre un peu
dans tous les labels parce
qu'aujourd'hui il existe différents
labels mais en réalité lesquels sont
performants ou pas deuxièmement les
contrôles il n'y a pas de contrôle
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui une entreprise
veut avoir le label ceci cela il va
l'obtenir très facilement mais est-ce
que vraiment ils arrivent à faire les
bons travaux en réalité Personne
contrôle derrière donc ça veut dire
qu'il y a énormément d'argent public qui
est utilisé pour favoriser les
entreprises qui se disent mieux disant
dans dans la protection de
l'environnement mais en réalité il y a
pas de contrôle derrière je vous donne
un exemple très simple vous avez du
simple vitrage vous voulez passer à du
double vitrage c'est très bien
[Musique]
vous connaissez aide territoire.gouv.fr
oui je connais c'est un peu ça mais en
version un peu data
contribuer à
répondre à la question aux questions de
même le rapporteur vous souhaitez
vous apporter une réponse je vous en
prie merci beaucoup alors l'association
de France émet un avis réservé sur votre
proposition nous considérons qu'il
serait préférable dans un premier temps
de sensibiliser les collectivités ou
leurs intercommunalités à embaucher des
personnes dédiées à la gestion des
fluides tels que les économes de flux
tels que notre collègue a évoqué tout à
l'heure sur son intercommunalité
que ce sont des postes clés qui peuvent
être qui peuvent grandement orienter les
collectivités dans leur cadre de la
transition énergétique de leur bâtiment
et qui accompagnent aussi le diagnostic
du patrimoine public de manière plus
générale donc des fonctions qui
pourraient ensuite être redéployées sur
d'autres bâtiments publics il nous
semble que cette réflexion comme le
disait notre collègue de Marseille doit
être géré au plus du terrain pour
vraiment tenir compte de la spécificité
de nos écoles et tout à l'heure il est
évoquait les différents typologies
d'écoles les écoles Jules Ferry les
écoles aquarium que nous ne connaissons
pas nous en millions rural mais qui je
suis prête à découvrir bien évidemment
et d'autres types d'écoles qui soient
plus emprise avec le réel et qui puisse
comme ça être aussi en adéquation avec
les budgets que les collectivités sont
en capacité de consacrer à cette
ambition que nous partageons
agir sur les économies d'énergie ce
n'est pas forcément refaire une école en
totalité mais c'est agir comme on le dit
comme il le disait lui-même tout à
l'heure sur la sur le remplacement des
huisseries sur l'installation de double
flux sur le travail de l'isolation et il
nous semble que ce travail fin ne peut
être fait qu'en proximité
voilà qui est clair
je vous en prie
d'écouter je voudrais remercier Monsieur
ganodszi et Madame le Maire
effectivement pour leurs interventions
alors c'est vrai que pour répondre aux
impératifs de rénovation les
intercommunalités sont plutôt bien
placés mais si elles veulent structurer
à la fois une ingénierie à l'échelle
locale elles sont confrontées donc à
l'ampleur de la tâche comme je disais
tout à l'heure puisqu'il n'y a pas que
le bâti scolaire il y a le bâti en
général donc
mettre à disposition des communes cet
ingénierie à la fois technique et
financière puisque les petites communes
n'ont souvent pas les moyens nous le
voyons bien nous avec toutes les
communes rurales qui n'ont pas qui n'ont
pas l'ingénierie ni technique ni
financière à disposition et qui
attendent de nous qu'on vienne en appui
et bien oui sur le principe mais à la
condition de pouvoir avoir les
ressources humaines pour pouvoir le
faire c'est aujourd'hui là que que ça
bloque sur le guichet unique ben il nous
semble que
nous intercommiter nous pouvons
travailler avec nos sous-préfet nos
préfets qui aujourd'hui par exemple gère
le fond vert le dialogue il est facile
il y a la DDT qui pourrait qui pourrait
intervenir en appui pour clarifier
clarifier les les aides qui sont
aujourd'hui disponibles je voudrais
rebondir sur ce qu'a dit Monsieur
ganotti sur la l'approche que nous avons
nous sur le terrain elle n'est pas une
uniquement une approche technique sur le
la rénovation énergétique c'est une
approche globale je pense que nous
devons avoir pour nos écoles nos
bâtiments scolaires une approche globale
c'est une approche transition écologique
au sens large pour intégrer tous les
enjeux air climat énergie santé sur
l'air c'est la qualité de l'air
intérieur dans l'importance a été mise
en évidence durant la pandémie sur le
climat c'est la désinterméabilisation
des des cours d'école des espaces des
espaces extérieurs qui doivent permettre
l'infiltration de l'eau et donc
l'abaissement des températures en été et
de manière générale la gestion de l'eau
avec la récupération par exemple de
l'eau de pluie pour générer des
économies d'eau ou des économiseurs
d'eau type mousseur sur l'énergie bah
c'est la production d'énergie puisque on
peut aller vers un bâti scolaire en
autoconsommation c'est possible avec
notamment des panneaux photovoltaïques
en toiture alors à la condition qu'on
soit un peu aidée par les bâtiments de
France parce que très vite on se rend
compte nous avec les communes qui ont
voulu en faire l'expérience que quand on
est dès qu'on est dans un périmètre et
c'est bien le souvent le cas des écoles
dans un périmètre de d'église ou de
bâtiments remarquable et bien on a des
refus ce que je trouve ce que je trouve
dommage et enfin on a les notions de
santé et sécurité de nos jeunes quand on
sait que de nombreux bâtiments ont été
construits dans les entre dans les
années 60 70 on a encore des bâtiments
où il subsistent des structures
métalliques pas uniquement des la
structure type Pailleron mais on a
encore des bâtiments qui sont on va dire
de vrais passoires thermiques et puis on
a aussi la problématique de l'amiante
donc je pense que c'est la transition
écologique au sens large qu'il faut
qu'on aborde et parce qu'on se rend
compte que quand on commence à faire des
travaux de rénovation énergétique ben on
se pose toutes ces autres questions et
donc il faut qu'on ait les ressources
les moyens financiers aussi humains qui
nous permettent de répondre à tous ces
problématiques
merci tout à l'heure vous avez parlé du
Guide de la cellule bâtisse scolaire
est-ce que vous en avez tous
connaissances et quel est votre regard
sur sur ce guide
moi je trouve qu'ils sont qui sont très
utiles ça permet de mutualiser toutes
les connaissances qui ont pu être
réalisées dans différentes communes donc
notamment Marseille puisque je le répète
les le cahier des charges qui a été qui
a été rédigé à Marseille et pour les
pour la rénovation de 10 écolesgep donc
disait quoi la structure métallique
donc on a réalisé des charges donc des
équipements d'escaliers des charges en
fait ce cahier des charges a été partagé
avec la cellule du bâti scolaire et je
trouve que arrivé à mutualiser les
bonnes pratiques je trouve ça bien il y
a pas de il y a pas d'aspect obligatoire
il y a pas de coercition vis-à-vis de
personnes en revanche il y a voilà il y
a l'idée de de ce que je disais voilà de
mutualiser les bonnes idées et d'aller
et d'aller vers des bâtiments scolaires
qui sont à la fois moins énergivores et
qui correspondent mieux aux défis de
l'éducation du XXIe siècle parce que
effectivement comme comme vous le dire
Madame réunion de Mongon il y a il y a
l'aspect thermique
d'adaptation au dérèglement climatique
mais il y a aussi tout ce qui va à côté
la sécurité des bâtiments ce que moi
j'ai appelé 3S santé sécurité et sureté
et ça c'est un défi quand je disais tout
à l'heure qui avait 1,2 milliards je
voulais bien dit ce n'est pas que pour
l'aspect thermique c'est la totalité qui
englobe les la remise à niveau en fait
de toutes les écoles de la ville de
Marseille et ce qui fait que si on
extrapole alors Marseille c'est un cas
particulier parce qu'on était très très
en retard de plusieurs dizaines d'années
mais si on extrapole à l'échelle de de
la France ça fait des ça fait des
milliards et des milliards d'euros pour
pouvoir y parvenir
je crois que dans le rapport de Marc il
doit parler de 40 milliards 4 milliards
par an sur 10 ans
ça fait effectivement beaucoup quelqu'un
d'autre veut réagir par rapport au bâtis
ce que
oui je veux bien puisque au titre de
l'AMF nous avons été associés mais
finalement peu associé et donc nous ne
sommes pas très satisfaits de la
démarche qui a été proposée donc la MF
en lien avec territoire unie a réagi
fermement auprès du ministre de
l'éducation nationale pour déplorer la
méthode employée qui sur la cellule
bâtie scolaire qui a d'abord qui a
plutôt reposé sur de l'information
descendante que sur de la concertation
alors que le patinoire ne bâtit scolaire
et de compétences des collectivités
territoriales donc nous avons dénoncé
cette méthode de travail sur la forme
sur le fond plusieurs remarques ont été
formulées notamment par territoire Unis
auprès du ministre de l'éducation
nationale qui ne cautionne pas le
contenu du guide et pour lequel il
reçoit qu'un certain nombre de fiches
sont strictement les mêmes dans leur
contenu pour les écoles maternelles les
écoles élémentaires les collèges ainsi
que les lycées et
j'ai évoqué en introduction de nos de
nos de cette séance de travail qu'il
fallait avoir une approche différenciée
entre les écoles maternelles les écoles
les élémentaires mais bien évidemment
avec les collèges et les lycées donc il
y a notamment une fiche qui concerne le
numérique qui est strictement la même
pour quel que soit le type
d'établissement ce qui n'est pas
évidemment entendable
territoire unir appelé ce que notre
collègue de l'intercommunalité rappelée
que ce que nous avons besoin sur les
territoires c'est davantage d'ingénierie
et de moyens humains pour accompagner
les communes dans la mise en place de
ces rénovations et de ses financements
et nous rappelons comme je l'ai fait
précédemment que ce guide doit être
complété doit absolument contenir une
fiche sur la liste des financements
disponibles
complément je voudrais intervenir sur
deux sujets il a été beaucoup fait
référence au fond vert
en même temps il faut en rappeler les
limites il y a une limite d'enveloppes
financière qui aujourd'hui le fond vert
par rapport aux enjeux climatiques c'est
un vingtième en étant très optimiste et
par ailleurs
le fond vert aujourd'hui ne permet de
recycler entre guillemets que des
travaux qui sont déjà actés c'est-à-dire
qu'on ne peut solliciter le fond vert
que pour des travaux 2023
ce qui par rapport aux enjeux scolaires
n'a pas de sens on est obligatoirement
dans la purée annualité et y compris
pour ce qui concerne les grandes villes
dans le pluri établissement on ne va pas
travailler que sur une classe ou une
école deuxième élément sur la
mutualisation et je voudrais insister
sur ce point-là qu'on développe beaucoup
à France urbaine oui l'école globalement
est souvent voisine d'une maison des
associations
ce qui fait que on des enjeux
en termes d'énergie en termes de
sécurité etc qui sont doublés
aujourd'hui la mutualisation doit
concerner l'école mais doit également
concerner ces pôles de centralité
lorsque vous avez une capacité de
fabriquer de la nourriture dans des
conditions
les meilleures l'école a les meilleurs
des conditions au plan de l'hygiène
lorsque vous avez la capacité de
stationnement lorsque vous avez des
espaces polyvalents il faut également
réfléchir il faut pas qu'on soit
uniquement dans l'idée que l'école est
un bien qui n'appartient qu'à lui-même
il faut vraiment qu'on ait une réflexion
qui aille au-delà on a évoqué les cours
oasis on a évoqué globalement la place
de l'école dans le quartier ou dans la
cité il faut qu'on ait vraiment une
réflexion qui aille au-delà du seul
bâtiment dédié à l'éducation
moi j'ai une question concernant on voit
bien que le financement on voit bien que
les collectivités sont face à un mur
d'investissement
que leur situation n'est pas toujours
même si la Cour des comptes considère
qu'elle est plutôt bonne quand on
regarde de plus près on s'aperçoit que
c'est très varié que cette le monde des
collectivités n'est pas un monde
homogène et qui a des difficultés pour
certaines d'entre elles
première question est-ce que vous pensez
que les objectifs qui ont été fixés sont
pas
trop élevées compte tenu du calendrier
qui est lui-même
imposé deuxième question est-ce que vous
considérez que vous avez certains
évoquent
la bonne dette et la mauvaise dette je
veux pas vous faire le coup du bon
chasseur mais certains considèrent que
la dette
justifiée par l'atteinte des objectifs
en matière de transition énergétique est
une bonne dette et qu'il faudrait la
séparer en tout y compris dans les
budgets locaux régionaux départementaux
pour que ça ne dégrade pas les ratios
parce que en termes de communication
c'est jamais bon auprès des banques pas
plus et donc si on allait vers une
séparation des choses ça serait
mieux accepté par les collectivités
parce que de toute façon vous le
rappeliez à l'instant le fond vert c'est
2 milliards et dans ces 2 milliards il y
a beaucoup de recyclage le fond friche
et dans les 2 milliards enfin c'est pas
de l'argent frais à hauteur de 2
milliards c'est compliqué parce que la
France a un problème de financement
global quand on a 3000 milliards d'euros
de dettes on a plus beaucoup de marge de
manœuvre je sais pas ce que vous pensez
par exemple de l'initiative récente et
qui a été votée large majorité au
Parlement sur le tiers financement je ne
sais pas si ça si ça vous intéresse ou
pas et voyez où est-ce que vous trouvez
que
cette question-là de dissocier de la
dette celle qui relève des
investissements
verts et est-ce que vous considérez que
les dates sont trop trop serrées parce
que comme vous le disiez les uns les
autres il n'y a pas que cela dans la
commune le batiste scolaire c'est certes
important mais il y a d'autres dépenses
liées à la culture liées à la au sport
enfin de toutes les compétences que
portent les le blocs local et une
question en direction de Madame la mère
de qui représente la MRF
je vais te parler tout à l'heure de mur
d'investissement est-ce que vous ne
craignez pas que bonne nouvelle ou
mauvaise nouvelle que
c'est charges qui vont qui se qui sont à
l'horizon
n'oublie certaines communes plutôt que
les financés seuls à se regrouper à
créer des regroupements pédagogiques qui
pourraient être annonciateur d'un
groupement plus intégré par la suite je
sais que vous êtes attaché à je vous
comprends et je fais partie de cela
attaché à l'identité à l'existence des
petites communes mais ce qui vous ne
voyez pas là à danger pour pour la suite
alors merci beaucoup de votre question
probablement que certaines communes
envisageons des regroupements auront les
forcera aussi à se regrouper parce que
il y a parfois des réalités de terrain
des choses qui nous obligent c'est vrai
que quand on a un gros projet de
rénovation d'une école restructuration
rénovation énergétique enfin voilà tout
ça ça peut impecter aussi beaucoup
d'autres projets en cours et que ça peut
devenir
contenu des faibles moyens financiers
qu'on peut avoir parce que on a des
communes quand même qui ont des tout
petits budgets on est très très
dépendants des dotations de l'État
il fallait principal recettes ce sont
les dotations et
les impôts qui nous reviennent
maintenant principalement le foncier
puisqu'on a pu le taxe d'habitation et
les capacités d'autofinancement sont en
train de diminuer terriblement
comme les villes sans doute mais alors
c'est pas dans les mêmes dans les mêmes
proportions évidemment puisque nous ça
se compte en dizaines de milliers
d'euros souvent petite dizaines de
milliers d'euros
et que et que cette réalité financière
elle est
en train de nous rattraper tous de nous
inquiéter parce qu'on
voit bien là on est dans la période de
préparation de nos budgets de nos de nos
budgets et comme ailleurs l'augmentation
de l'énergie la masse salariale les
obligations qu'on peut avoir toutes ces
différentes normes et tout ce qu'on nous
impose tout ce qui arrive de tous les
côtés je crois qu'à un moment oui
effectivement on ne saura plus comment
faire
après ce qui nous a sauvé un petit peu
jusqu'à présent dans les petites
communes c'est le bon sens qu'on pouvait
continuer à appliquer c'est-à-dire quand
on a voulu nous imposer tous les
capteurs de CO2 dans les écoles au
moment du covid et qu'on a été assez
nombreux à résister le bon sens c'est
quand même d'ouvrir connaître très
régulièrement sans forcément et les
équiper d'appareils qui sont coûteux
donc il faut qu'il faut surveiller après
etc
il y a des moments restants quand même
elle est chose très très simples comme
le disait le collègue évidemment les
aquariums quand on peut pas ouvrir les
fenêtres c'est grave je trouve
à l'heure actuelle qu'on soit en milieu
rural ou urbain
[Musique]
gardons les pieds sur terre voilà
les
regroupements pédagogiques peuvent dans
certains cas être souhaité
par les écoles et pourquoi pas nous
faire
projeté dans des pôles éducatifs comme
on a pu le croire il y a quelques années
comme on voulait un peu nos orienter il
y a quelques années la majoritairement
les communes rurales c'est non je veux
dire on a des problèmes de mobilité de
distance à parcourir le
carburant etc enfin même pour un
regroupement pédagogique à l'heure
actuelle quand on réfléchit bien ça a
pas beaucoup de sens
si ce n'est
d'éviter des tout petits électifs
effectifs dans des dans des classes
uniques voilà mais mais
voilà l'attachement des élus à leur
petite école aussi petite soit elle
les oblige leur
fait faire beaucoup de choses voilà
très bien
dette
trois réponses la première c'est que
dans cette période où les collectivités
doivent subir l'augmentation des coûts
de l'énergie le problème va être de
voter des comptes administratifs qui
dégageront suffisamment pour rembourser
la nuité de la dette autrement vous le
savez nous ne sommes pas comme l'état
nous sommes obligatairement mis sous
tutelle donc même si la dette est une
bonne dette c'est nous ne pouvons pas la
rembourser en fin d'exercice nous sommes
dans l'illégalité deuxième élément
moi j'ai été maire d'une commune moyenne
en Île-de-France pendant assez longtemps
qui s'appelle Juvisy et à l'époque j'ai
connu la mode des PPP des programmations
publiques privées c'était extraordinaire
et on nous a vendu ça les écoles les
hôpitaux etc en fait on s'est rendu
compte que sur des durées
d'amortissement inférieur à 50 ans ça
coûtait beaucoup plus d'argent que ce
qu'on arrivait à économiser aujourd'hui
on nous parle de bonnes ou de moyens
d'être vous avez raison sur le fond si
vous avez une durée d'amortissement d'un
bien qui est de l'ordre de 30 ans faire
supporter par les contribuables des
trois décennies l'acquisition ou la
rénovation de ce bien et est intelligent
problème c'est que aujourd'hui ni le
Code général ni les conditions que les
banques mettent pour prêter aux communes
nous avons quand même connu une période
où il y avait de nombreuses communes qui
n'avaient plus de prêteurs donc ne nous
permettent de spéculer sur cet enjeu
alors effectivement si on a une
évolution des règles de finance publique
peut-être qu'à ce moment-là on pourrait
raisonner sur une dette qui dépend de la
capacité d'amortissement avec quand même
cette précaution de l'augmentation des
taux d'intérêt
petite remarque sur sur le calendrier et
les coûts le chiffre de 40 milliards sur
10 ans c'est date 2020 c'est à dire
precovid pré guerre en Ukraine et pré
Chris bancaire c'est l'indicatif donc
oui sauf que l'indicatif aujourd'hui il
a complètement explosé si je prends
l'exemple de Marseille par rapport à ce
que nous avions envisagé comme coût sur
sur des écoles en rénovation complète on
se rend compte qu'aujourd'hui qu'on est
allègrement entre 15 et 25% de surcoût
par rapport à ce qui avait été fléché il
y a encore un an et demi donc le
calendrier c'est très bien de vouloir
être de vouloir aller vite sauf que le
corollaire de la vitesse c'est un la
saturation des marchés pour les
entreprises de BTP
et du coup ça veut dire un surcoût
global parce qu'en fait comme toutes les
entreprises ont des carnets de commandes
qui sont pleins les prix s'envolent
c'est exactement ce que nous avons comme
problème à Marseille ou aujourd'hui
en fait on a du mal à trouver des
entreprises qui nous répondent aux prix
que nous demandons et donc on est obligé
de réélever mais sauf qu'on peut pas
payer nous à Marseille parce qu'on a dit
on a 1000 focus sur les écoles on va pas
payer des écoles au prix d'un collège
c'est pas possible donc allez vite c'est
bien mais il y a quand même un danger
qui est l'inflation induite par ça de le
risque que la main d'oeuvre ou le les
secteurs du BTP ne puisse pas y répondre
on a du mal à Marseille alors j'imagine
que dans des communes rurales le
problème va être encore plus important
et et tout ça risque de en fait saturer
le marché à moins évidemment de
considérer qu'on fasse venir des
entreprises du fin fond de l'Europe ou
de la Chine ou le retour du plombier
polonais je sais pas mais sinon ça va
être extrêmement important et troisième
chose ça veut dire aussi et on a
commencé à le faire avec le rectorat il
y a un vrai travail à réaliser sur les
cartes de formation parce que si à
Marseille est partout en France on met
le focus sur on va dire grosso modo le
décrétaire et respecter ce des critère
ça veut dire des milliers et des
milliers d'emplois certaines disent même
un million d'emplois pour les emplois
verts mais aujourd'hui on ne les a pas
ces emplois verts donc c'est à dire que
les cartes de formation dans tous les
métiers du BTP au sein de l'art du terme
de de l'économe de flux qui est une
perle extrêmement rare dans les Ardennes
comme à Marseille à l'ingénieur
thermique l’ingénieur acousticien ou le
maçon ce sont des métiers d'avenir et ça
je pense que on doit l'accentuer et dans
toutes les formations qu'elle soit Greta
lycée pro ou autre il faut vraiment être
là-dessus
vous sentez nettement à Marseille que la
commune devient vache allée parce que
les entreprises profitent de la
circonstance pour organiser les choses
et augmenter leur prix ce n'est pas moi
qui l'ai dit
c'est ma traduction
vous avez un bon traducteur
est-ce que
sur les constats portés par les trois
interventions précédentes évidemment
nous les nous les partageons y compris
l'inflation de 20 à 25% sur les marchés
que nous devons
à affecter pour la rénovation des écoles
c'est un vrai sujet c'est un vrai sujet
je crois que il faudra avoir un dialogue
franc notamment avec la Fédération
française du bâtiment et pour ma part
comme le président national est à
Périgueux je m'entraîne je vais
m'entretenir avec lui dès demain je
déjeune avec lui sur ces questions sur
ces questions de capacité à répondre au
marché et puis sur cette inflation qui
n'est pas toujours justifiée comme
l'indiqué notre collègue de Marseille
sur la question que vous nous posez du
respect du calendrier concernant la mise
en oeuvre de l'article 22 24-34 du CGT
sur la sur la loi énergie et climat le
rapport de marque de 2020 mentionné que
les décrets devaient être complétés
d'une circulaire qui n'est toujours pas
à notre disposition et qui permettrait
d'éclairer à la fois en termes de
calendrier et de méthodologie la mise en
oeuvre de cette ambition que nous
portons et donc pour lesquelles mes
collègues précédents ont indiqué les
difficultés à le porter tant sur le plan
technique par la capacité à avoir des
entreprises qui répondent au marché que
par la capacité financière à le financer
sur cette question de la dette et bien
en effet comme le disait notre collègue
sur le plan réglementaire cela
aujourd'hui n'est pas possible d'isoler
cette dette cette bonne dette comme vous
l'indiquez de dans nos comptes
administratifs et qui présentent une
difficulté sur la question du
du tiers financement de rénovation du
bâti scolaire
dans le cas législatif est en cours
d'adoption et pour lesquelles une
expérimentation est proposée le premier
réflexe évidemment celui qui évoquait
notre collègue de prudence nous avons
connu ces fameux PPP qui n'ont pas
toujours été et notamment nous en
proximité à Bordeaux nous avons connu
sur un équipement public le stade des
contexte qu'il nous faut être très
prudent sur l'outil pour autant un
certain nombre de communes sont prêtes à
expérimenter ce dispositif ouvert aux
collectivités dans le cadre expérimental
mais nous rappelons qu'il est toujours
nécessaire de réaliser une étude
préalable à la soutenabilité budgétaire
afin d'avoir accès au tiers financement
et rappeler aussi qu'en effet on a un
grand nombre de nos communes qui
aujourd'hui ne peuvent de nouveau plus
accéder à des prêts bancaires tant les
taux sont élevés et continues de pré
progresser
merci alors comme vous rencontrez demain
le président de la Fédération française
du bâtiment nous les avons reçus la
semaine dernière
à la fois la Fédération française du
bâtiment et la CAPEB et en fait nous
avons beaucoup insisté sur le besoin de
main d'oeuvre qui est un secteur que je
connais bien puisque j'étais responsable
d'équipe dans un pôle emploi auparavant
donc je vois bien les difficultés et on
nous a répondu qu'il n'y avait aucun
souci à plusieurs reprises donc
peut-être que vous aurez des pistes
demain matin
lors du déjeuner on sera on sera preneur
des pistes pour effectivement il nous
disent à quel point il y aura aucun
souci pour qu'on puisse qu'on puisse
former parce qu'il y a à la fois l'offre
de formation de l'éducation nationale
qui qui doit aussi être mise en oeuvre
mais il y a également tout ce qui peut
se passer au niveau
expérimentation dans les régions aussi
et en région Bretagne on est assez
novateur pour faire des actions
tutoriel expérimental et là on répond au
plus proche du terrain sur de la
formation très très ciblée et on arrive
à à faire en sorte de mettre des
personnes en fait sur des métiers qui
peuvent être d'avenir mais du coup voilà
si vous avez des pistes intéressantes
demain je suis nous sommes tous preneurs
je voudrais juste préciser que j'ai bien
compris qu'une dette reste une dette
et qu'elle soit verte ou pas il faut la
rembourser mais je vais évoqué un
discours que qu'on entend de plus en
plus souvent c'est pas le mien qui
consiste non pas à nier qu'une dette est
une dette mais à séparer la dette pour
que
politiquement l'opinion publique
comprennent mieux la situation dans
laquelle je trouve une collectivité mais
il y a pas la bonne la mauvaise dette il
y a une dette et il faut la rembourser
s'agissant
[Musique]
du tiers financement
ça a été voté ça a été voté à une large
majorité tant ici que
l'Assemblée nationale mais vous savez
que l'affaire des PPP avait été
traumatisante à l'époque et que beaucoup
avaient regretté de s'y être engagé mais
là c'est quelque chose d'autre d'abord
c'est une possibilité personne était
obligé de s'engager dans cette voie mais
la différence avec le PPP c'est que il y
a pas ça ne concerne que l'opération
d'investissement la gestion qui
occupait pour partie le PPP et qui
laissait un très mauvais souvenir de
coexité n'est pas concerné et c'est une
expérimentation qui est ouverte pour une
durée de 5 ans
ça peut être une piste mais de la vue
même du ministre ça sera pas suffisant
parce qu'il faut trouver du financement
et de toute façon ce sera plus cher
parce qu'il faudra rembourser la dette
et la tirer
c'est deux sujets
tire financement mais ça a été très bien
dit Madame la mère de Périgueux
aujourd'hui
il y a une expérimentation qui qui est
proposée peut-être que cette
expérimentation permettra de nous
rassurer par rapport au PPP le PPP
n'avait pas objectif que de prendre en
charge les charges d'investissement
après la logique de déclinaison en bail
emphytéotique était une logique dont on
a très vite appris que sur une durée
d'amortissement assez brève le bail en
phytéotique coûtait plus cher que les
intérêts d'emprunt que nous aurions pu
payer là je mets de côté des travaux
d'infrastructures de mobilité qui sont
sur un amortissement très long et
autrement globalement les collectivités
pour l'essentiel on remboursé les PPP de
manière anticipée à leur frais ça leur a
coûté très cher et c'est l'inquiétude
que
nous avons par rapport au tiers
financement après sur la dette des
collectivités là aussi la dette des
collectivités par nature c'est une dette
vertueuse puisque les collectivités ne
peuvent s'endetter que pour financer de
l'investissement nous ne sommes pas dans
la situation de l'État qui s'en dette
pour le fonctionnement alors après on
peut contester on peut dire que l'école
est plus vertueux que l'équipement pour
personnes âgées que la voirie ou que
mais en revanche ce qui serait pour nous
très compliqué c'est de dire ben voilà
ce serait une forme de tutelle entre
guillemets en disant mais cette dette
est plus vertueuse qu'une autre parce
qu'elle va concerner un établissement
scolaire ce qui nous mettra dans une
situation extrêmement complexe donc
autant nous sommes d'accord sur le fait
que la dette des collectivités est en
soi vertueuse parce que globalement elle
permet d'emprunter sur des durées
d'amortissement de faire supporter à
plusieurs générations à bien qui
concernera cette génération après de la
segmenter ça me paraît à la fois
difficile et très complexe en termes de
libre administration
pour revenir sur les sur les PPP et les
partenariats publics privés j'ai été à
Marseille l'un des fers de lance contre
le PPP des écoles que qu'avaient voulu
l'ancienne municipalité donc je connais
bien le sujet maintenant ce dont on
parle avec le tiers financement c'est le
dernier P qui change c'est à dire que là
c'est un partenariat public mais public
et c'est exactement ce que nous nous
avons fait à Marseille avec dans le
cadre très précis d'une espèce la hyène
dans donc on appelle l'aspect la société
publique des écoles de Marseille où en
fait on a que du on a que des fonds
publics et que des acteurs publics donc
on a l'état d'un côté et on a la ville
de Marseille à 55 ans alors là pour le
tiers financement il faut avoir comment
ça se met en place donc ça sera une
expérimentation donc avoir commencé fait
mais moi je pense que s'il y a la Caisse
des Dépôts et Consignation donc la CDC
d'un côté l'état de l'autre et puis les
collectivités alors je pense plutôt
communal parce qu'effectivement toutes
les communes sont attachées quand même à
leur alors à leur école patrimoniale
je pense que ça peut aller vers quelque
chose de de plutôt bien et de plutôt
rassurant pour tout le monde parce qu'il
ne s'agira pas de de financer une
multinationale qui dont l'objectif n'est
pas la philanthropie c'est un sauf
erreur de ma part en revanche l'Etat on
peut estimer que on est dans le cadre du
service public et redonner en fait la
force de
la force de la force publique redonné
les marges de manœuvre pour que l'État
soit redevienne un aménageur du
territoire je pense que c'est plutôt un
bon outil même si effectivement on peut
s'inquiéter de certaines dérives qui a
pu avoir par le passé mais encore une
fois si le dernier P veut dire public et
non pas privé je pense qu'on peut être à
même à être rassuré il y a des écueils à
éviter c'est vrai nous avons invité à
Marseille tant mieux
mais nous ce que nous ce que nous
mettons en place c'est un PPP
partenariat public à 100%
je vous en prie monsieur le Président je
voudrais répondre à la question que vous
nous avez posé sur la finalement la
séparation des investissements
j'ai envie de dire qu'avec la crise
énergétique c'est ces derniers mois on a
vu tous les budgets des collectivités
ont explosé et elles ont dû à adopter en
urgence des mesures déjà en termes de
sobriété d'efficacité
extinction d'éclairage public fermeture
partielle de certains équipements
baisse des températures dans l'ensemble
des équipements en périodes hivernal
donc et tous les je pense les médias y
compris les médias locaux ont largement
relayé toutes ces mesures et donc
l'opinion publique maintenant et très
fortement sensibilisé donc on a
maintenant décidé et on a besoin tous de
d'accélérer de massifier tous nos
investissements mais quand je regarde
moi les compétences des intercos
il y a l'habitat les travaux les
mobilités les déchets l'économie
circulaire la préservation des milieux
naturels on voit en fait que les
investissements si on parle de
transition écologique on ne peut que les
aborder de manière globale et on ne peut
pas isoler me semble-t-il des
investissements qui seraient des
investissements verts parce que il faut
que tout vers 10 donc je pense que c'est
plus une approche qu'il faut qu'on ait
maintenant et que l'opinion il va
falloir ça nous accompagne déjà dans
cette démarche mais je pense que séparer
les investissements qui seraient liés à
la transition écologique ou énergétique
du reste ce n'est ça correspond pas à la
réalité de la façon dont nous abordons
nous nos politiques publiques
merci
est-ce que quelqu'un souhaite
on n'a pas de collègue en ligne non
est-ce que quelqu'un souhaite compléter
tes propos ou ajouter des propos à
ceux qui viennent d'être dit
si
je vous en prie excusez-moi juste je
pense que nous avons en réalité 30 ans
de retard on serait en 1995 on pourrait
parler en toute sérénité nous sommes
malheureusement en 2023 et ça urge sauf
que comme tout le monde l'a dit les
sommes sont absolument stratosphériques
et je crois vraiment que l'État doit
imposer des cahiers des charges très
forts très volontariste pas forcément
non plus avoir un calendrier trop
ambitieux parce que si on se retrouve
face à un mur qu'est-ce qu'elles vont
faire la plupart des communes vont dire
le mur il est trop haut je n'essaye même
pas de le sauter d'avoir quelque chose
qui les accompagne alors est-ce que
c'est bien financement est-ce que c'est
autre chose je ne sais pas ce sera
évidemment au sénateur au députés à
réfléchir à tout cela mais moi je crois
que on ne peut plus se permettre de
rester au pied du mur parce que
malheureusement la discussion que nous
avons aujourd'hui on aurait dû la voir
il y a bien longtemps que ce soit sur le
bâti scolaire comme sur l'ensemble des
bâtiments parce que plusieurs personnes
m'ont dit mais en réalité les la
consommation des écoles par rapport à
l'ensemble des des bâtiments publics ça
reste quand même pas à grand chose nous
à Marseille nous avons les casernes
parmi les casernes des pompiers puisque
à Marseille dans la particularité avoir
le bataillon des marins-pompiers qui est
qui est municipal les casernes sont des
gouffres thermiques absolument
considérables donc le les écoles
collèges lycée sont une consommation
importante mais ça reste petit par
rapport à l'ensemble et encore plus si
on compare par rapport aux immeubles
d'habitation au bailleur sociaux etc
donc nous sommes très en retard il nous
faut agir vite mais pas trop vite et
avec quelque chose qui soit acceptable
par tout le monde mais avec un
accompagnement de l'État très très fort
je pense
merci
très bien en visio pas de réaction
particulière tout ce que vous vouliez
dire vous vous l'avez dit si vous
souhaitez
compléter encore oui je vous en prie ce
sera la dernière oui un petit mot
simplement pour pour assurer les maires
qui sont très attachés comme les
citoyens et les familles du reste à
leurs écoles je voulais simplement
préciser que chez intercommunité de
France il y a aucune volonté de
transférer la la compétence je crois que
les maires sont vraiment des acteurs
locaux qui savent comment fonctionnent
leurs écoles qui connaissent les
familles et les citoyens de leur commune
mieux que personne et qui voilà et il
faut que les fonctionnements des écoles
reste dans les communes tout ça c'était
simplement ça et je voudrais simplement
dire aussi que il y a un paradoxe avec
la gendar rurale moi je viens des
départements quand même très rural les
Ardennes et en fait la difficulté qu'on
a c'est que on a beaucoup d'écoles qui
sont menacées fermeture parce qu'elles
sont à moitié vides du fait de la
déprise démographique et aussi de
l'explosion des coûts liés à l'énergie
et que ça c'est un sujet très sensible
parce que les décisions de fermeture
pour engager des rénovations de ou la
construction de bâtiments à des normes
actuelles peut constituer un frein
politique qu'il faut pas ignorer dans
nos communes rurales merci
[Musique]
colossal et que tout quand tout devient
prioritaire ça pose ça pose vous avez un
résoudre une équation qui est vraiment
très complexe
et si vous
si vous le souhaitez vous bien sûr nous
envoyer par écrit les documents que vous
pensez
utile qu'ils soient mis porté entre
connaissance merci à tous et à toutes et
je vous souhaite une
agréable après un agréable après-midi au
revoir